please welcome someone i've known and
loved for many years
sawyer spielberg
hello hi sawyer
it's great to see you oh it's always so
wonderful to see you
you know you're a man now and a dad
yes yes i've been a father now
for 15 months and
incredible
speaking of fathers and daughters i
don't know although i'm not
your father's daughter i am so
much of who i am because of your dad's
support of me growing up you know i've
heard stories
about when my father was working with
you on e.t
it may have been the first time in his
life where
he considered being a father that's how
powerful your relationship was
with my dad well thank you for saying
that because he really changed
my life i can pretty much trace all the
origin stories
of so many things back to him
and i love the story of how he would
wake you up in the morning
will you tell me about that when i was a
teenager i
had a hard time getting up for school
and uh one morning he came in and he
said okay
i'm a director you're an actor i'm gonna
barge into your room
and i'm gonna say action and you have to
get up brush your teeth
get dressed and head down for breakfast
and uh sure enough he came in he said
action
and i got up brushed my teeth came
downstairs for breakfast and it worked
so his uh his directing skills have have
worked in both
the uh the cinema and at home well um
sawyer i'm gonna go home and try that on
my daughter olive tonight
um or tomorrow morning because if i say
this is what stephen does
then they'll maybe fall in line i'll
come back and let you know how it goes
now sawyer
i am terrified by your new movie
honeydew
it is what i love is the
acting and the way that it's filmed it
sort of hearkens back to another era of
filmmaking
um it gives me like 70s 80s like texas
chainsaw
kind of you know i even think of like
sugarland express with your dad it
kind of looks like when i think
the genre was really compelling of
horror films and yet it's got like
appetite of like the get outs and when
people can really get into the
psychology
and i am really excited for this film i
think it truly delivers it's
so scary and creepy
and frightening and freaky thank you
the the director and and i and the whole
team of honeydew
we we all really have a lot of
appreciation for the 70s and 80s and the
traditional way of making movies
um where it's very character driven
and so i really i really appreciate that
you can you can see that and respect
that and i'm excited for
everybody else to be able to experience
that if you are
a horror movie uh fan and if you can
take
the disturbing elements of this film
well like i said i think for those who
want it they're gonna get it
and sawyer it's just so nice to see you
and congratulate you on your fatherhood
and i've actually asked your mom the
great cake cap shaw
many of uh different moments of advice
as she is such a brilliant salient
smart creative incredible force of a
human and i just love her so much too as
we've talked about your dad
my goodness if your mom isn't one of the
great women of the world i don't know
who is
oh yeah i mean my mom is the reason why
i
i'm an actor she's the reason for
everything you know
and she's been such an incredible
mother and grandmother to my daughter
and and they built such a strong bond
during the pandemics and she's got that
incredible
um sensitivity and wisdom that she's
been passing down to my wife ray
and myself and i'm very lucky and
grateful that my daughter gets to have
a grandmother and a grandfather like my
parents
she's amazing i love your family so much
and i'm so glad to have lived my life
alongside of you guys
and i'm so excited for your new film and
i think it's going to be an awesome
success and
i will see you soon sawyer i hope i look
forward to seeing you soon drew
me too sawyer see you around
[Music]